[Music]
oh yeah we are back for another
real-life English and learning TV lesson
from friends and today we're going to
help you not just learn it but live it
once again and you're going to laugh
your ass off is Chandler who is straight
discovers that women his entire life has
always thought that he was gay as always
recommend you follow the real life power
learning method which we developed with
our fluent with friends course first you
simply watch the scene with or without
subtitles in this video there will be
subtitles if you need them and we will
underline the words we're going to teach
second you will study the video with a
five-minute lesson breaking down all the
most important vocab pronunciation
grammar and cultural notes
we also recommend you download this free
five page free PDF power lesson taken
directly from our 11-month bloomin
friends power learning course study it
learn it master download on the link
above and finally watch the scene again
without subtitles and live it we'll be
publishing many more videos like this so
if you like these videos please click
Subscribe hey gorgeous type of dollar
question you're not dating anybody are
you because I'm as somebody who would be
perfect for you thought you see perfect
might be a problem had you said
codependent or self-destructive do you
want to date Saturday yes please okay
he is cute he's funny he's a chi oh yeah
oh god I just
Kelly okay I'm just going to go flush
myself down the toilet now okay is that
ridiculous can you believe she actually
thought that um yeah by me when I first
met you you know I thought maybe
possibly you might be you did yeah but
then you spent Phoebe's entire birthday
party talking to my breasts so then I
figured maybe not oh good I mean the
rest of you guys think that when you
first met me I did not think so not me
not um me neither
although uh you know back in college
Susan salad or did you're kidding
did you tell her I wasn't no sorry
sister I kind of wanted to go out with
her too so I told her actually you were
seeing Bernie Spellman who also like
Wow this is fascinating so what is it
about I don't know because you're smart
you're funny lots of smart and funny do
you ever think that about him ok I don't
know you just you have a quality yes yes
right hey gorgeous
Hey look I'm sorry about yesterday I you
don't believe me apparently other people
have made the same mistake oh ok cute so
uh what do you think it is about I don't
know what you just have a quality right
it was a shame because you and Lowell
would have made a great couple
Lowell Financial Services Lowell that's
how you saw me with what he's cute oh
yeah no Brian and payroll is Brian no
look I don't know point is that if
you're going to set me up with someone
I'd like to thank you would set me up
with somebody like him well I think
Brian's a little out of your league
excuse me you don't think I could get a
Brian because I could get a Brian
believe you me I'm really not I love you
guys you guys are the greatest
I love my sister love easy oh hey
Chandler hey I love you man
Ross is acting funny here because he is
high or intoxicated on prescription pain
medication because he injured his leg
and took too many pills and listen man
if you want to be gay be gay doesn't
matter to me you were right
hey Lowell oh hey Chandler listen um I
don't know what Shelly told you about me
but I'm not you know that's what I told
her
really yeah so you can tell pretty much
most of the time we have a kind of radar
so you don't think I have a quality
speaking for my people I'd have to say
no by the way your friend Brian from
payroll he is he is yep and way out of
your league out of my league I could get
a Brian I wanted to get a Brian I could
get a Brian hey Brian you're not dating
anybody are you to date someone to go
out or meet with somebody with the
intention of getting romantically
involved date as a noun as the meeting
with that person had you said
codependent or self-destructive
codependent type of unhealthy
relationship where each person supports
the dysfunction of the other person
self-destructive the type of dysfunction
where people tend to harm or hurt or
even destroy themselves
he is cute he's funny cute another word
for attractive or beautiful but more
innocent which often represents the
first stage of romantic interest hey
gorgeous gorgeous another word for
beautiful but more sensual with some
people like Shelley and Chandler words
like this are often used in a playful
way to address friends of the opposite
sex so then I figured maybe not that
figured another way to say I thought I
assumed we arrived at the conclusion
that for example I've had this hairstyle
forever so I figured it was time for a
change the rest of you guys think that
the rest you guys think
the rest of you guys think that when you
first met me back in college Susan salad
or did back in used to make a reference
to a time in the past for example they
founded the company back in the early
90s you're kidding
did you tell her out what you're kidding
another way of saying you're joking this
is more commonly said as a question of
surprise or when you can't believe
something really happened
for example are you kidding if you
really just lose your phone again did
you tell her I was did you tell her I
was did you tell her I watch dogs
because I like these guys I kind of want
to go out with her too I kind of want to
go out with two mice I don't want them
to go out with her too so what is it
about so uh we actually knew so to
simply start a conversation
other times we also use it to start
talking about a certain topic when we
don't know exactly what the most
sophisticated way to do it is or even
when we're a bit nervous for example so
as anyone besides me going to do the
dishes this time did you ever think that
about him sure yeah do you ever think
that about him oh okay cute whew
what we say well want to relieved about
something optin putting your hand on
your forehead to wipe away the sweat
from your worry
Shelly even made this gesture for
example whew I'm glad to hear that no
one got hurt in the accident
it is a shame because you and Lowell
would have made a great couple
it's a shame another way of saying it's
a pity we say this when we think that
something is unfortunate for example
it's a shame she won't come a couple two
people in a romantic relationship for
example are they a couple or really
close friends would have made a great
couple protonated right okay would have
made a great public no Brian and payroll
and payroll this refers to a company's
list of employees and the amount of
money has been paid to those employees
in this case payroll is an area of the
company where law works but if you're
going to set me up with someone I'd like
to thank you would set me up with
somebody like him to set you up with
another person
the plan is strategy to bring two people
together for a romantic
or a date for example she's single
because she wants to be so people should
stop trying to set her up with guys well
I think Brian's a little out of your
league
out of one's league this is said of
someone who you feel is so much more
attractive in you that he or she won't
go on a date with you for example I
didn't ask her on a date because I
thought she was out of my league
because I could get a break believe you
me believe you mean used to emphasize
the truth of something said for example
I'm gonna get that job believe you mean
doesn't matter to me doesn't matter to
me so you can tell he can tell so Sal is
to be able to distinguish or judge
something because of the existing
evidence for example I can tell it's
going to be a hard day of work okay I'm
just going to go flush myself down the
toilet yeah flush myself down the toilet
flush the toilet means cleaning the
toilet by causing large quantities of
water to pass through it he or she says
she will flush herself down the toilet
to show she's extremely embarrassed from
baking Chandler sexual orientation but
then you spent Phoebe's entire birthday
party talking to my friend so then I
figured maybe not talking to my breasts
but rachel is implying here is that
Chandler couldn't take his eyes off of
her breasts when they were chatting the
first time they met not be not on me
neither me neither me neither is used
like me too but in a negative sense for
example if somebody says I didn't do my
homework you can say me neither
okay I don't know you just you have a
quality you have a quality the guys have
a hard time putting words into exactly
what it is that makes Chandler appear
gay they could have said it's the way he
behaves but differ for a less obvious
direct alternative saying it's a quality
we have a kind of radar we have kind of
a radar this joke is referencing the
well-known the very informal concept of
a gaydar which is a person's ability to
judge whether someone is straight
heterosexual or gay
[Music]
hey gorgeous hypergolic
question he not dating anybody are you
because I know somebody would be perfect
for you thought you see the perfect
might be a problem
had you said codependent or
self-destructive do you want to date
Saturday yes please okay he is cute he's
funny he's a key oh yeah
oh god I just jelly
okay I'm just going to go flush myself
down the toilet now okay is that
ridiculous can you believe she actually
thought that um yeah well I mean when I
first met you you know I thought maybe
possibly you might be you did yeah but
then you spent Phoebe's entire birthday
party talking to my breasts so then I
figured maybe not oh good I mean the
rest of you guys think that when you
first met me I did I think so
not me not on me Nina although uh you
know back in college Susan salad or did
you're kidding
did you tell her I wasn't no sorry
because I I kind of want them to go out
with her too so I told her actually you
were seeing a Bernie Spellman
who also like them wow this is
fascinating so uh what is it about I
don't know
cuz you're smart you're funny lots of
smart and funny
do you ever think that about him okay I
don't know you just you have a quality
yes right hey gorgeous
Hey look I'm sorry about yesterday I you
know don't don't worry about it believe
me
apparently other people have made the
same mistake oh okay
cute so uh what do you think it is about
I don't know what you just have a
quality right right it was a shame
because you and lo would have made a
great couple
Lowell Financial Services Lowell that's
how you saw me with what he's cute oh
yeah no Brian and payroll
is Brian so look I don't know point is
that if you're going to set me up with
someone I'd like to thank you would set
me up with somebody like him well I
think Brian's a little out of your
league
excuse me you don't think I could get a
Brian because I could get a Brian
believe you me I'm really not I love you
guys you guys are the greatest I love my
sister love be beautiful oh hey Chandler
Hey I Love You Man
Calissa now if you want to be gay be gay
doesn't matter to me hey Lowell
oh hey Chandler listen um I don't know
what Shelly told you about me but I'm
not I know that's what I told her really
yeah so you can tell pretty much most of
the time we have a kind of radar so you
don't think I have a quality speaking
for my people I'd have to say no by the
way your friend Bryant from payroll he
is he is yep and way out of your league
out of my league I could get a Brian if
I wanted to get a Brian I could get a
Brian hey Brian
did you love this lesson then remember
to click here to join our free three
part mini course
teaching you English with your favorite
TV series